adieu tonneau ruine hangars et entrepôts
à bercy la pimprenelle le serpolet leurs
efforts et même les asperges
d'argenteuil vous mène dorénavant par le
bout du nez depuis le fameux baron
haussmann jamais paris exception faite
du parc andré citroën à l'effet
construit aussi grand jardin dans trois
ans quand il sera entièrement terminée
le parc de bercy représentera 8 experts
de plus pas en vert sur la carte de la
capitale mais déjà l'amoureux de la
nature peut découvrir une roseraie un
jardin de senteurs mais aussi des
treilles et des vignes
rappelant le passé de ce lieu autrefois
clos par crainte des maraudeurs respect
de l'environnement oblige ici les
marronniers centenaires ont même été
précieusement préserver paris est la
seule ville aujourd'hui en europe qui
donne à ce point là sa place au créateur
d' espaces verts est-ce qu'on peut
encore faire à paris en termes
d'aménagement des espaces verts il y
aura forcément à brève échéance une
réflexion qui sera menée sur la
possibilité d'aménager ou non le dernier
espace vert d'importance de paris le
dernier grand poumon vert la sncf est
propriétaire actuellement de 40 hectares
environ situé entre la porte de clichy
et la porte d'asnières possibilité donc
là de faire un très grand espace entre 8
et 12 hectares donc un parc avec bien
sûr à côté des aménagements immobiliers
en attendant toujours à bercy dans le
jardin romantique l'ultime étape de la
visite les pins de corse ou les djinns
coup vous offre du dépaysement pour pas
cher
et si vos yeux ne suffisent pas vous
pouvez toujours essayer de repartir
d'ici avec une fraise caché dans la main
avec une fleur d'artichaut camouflé dans
la poche